let's jump into this first story I love
this one from the hill First Republic
Fallout Democrats fume as Regulators
bail out yet another failed Bank what I
love about this is that they're like
while Democrats aren't arguing the body
Administration should have let First
Republic fail many are concerned that
the current Spate of Bank rescues point
to financial stability concerns I love
it Democrats basically coming out and
being like I can't believe they'd bail
out another bank I mean we want them to
do it but we're so shocked that they
didn't wearing yeah they wanted this to
happen they say the San francisco-based
Regional Powerhouse is the third major
U.S Bank to fail and prompt a government
administrative bailout of depositors
following the collapse of Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank in March it is
the second largest bank collapse in U.S
history eclipsing Silicon Valley Bank I
love this because it's like no one seems
to care it's just another domino falling
it's almost like it's not news that our
banking system is collapsing I wake up
it's 6 a.m I look at my phone and I'm
like my eyes are like stuck shut and I'm
like what's going on here I look at my
phone and it's like the federal
government seized First Republic Bank
this morning and sold it to JP Morgan
with 50 billion dollars in financing
from them and I'm like wait what at four
in the morning they did this wow it
sounds like it's all falling apart and
then throughout the rest of the day like
no one's talking about the first thing I
saw was your Tweet and I was like oh we
gotta write about this right away that
was our first story out today and
everyone was like oh wow how about that
you guys hear vices going bankrupt it's
like dude our banking system is bankrupt
yeah oh yeah but Vice sucks that's also
true I mean look our baking system sucks
too our banking system also sucks I
don't I I guess the issue is like we
know the banks are failing but what do
we do I feel like exactly I feel like
everybody that's kind of like the
situation everyone knows everyone's
aware of how much money has been printed
in the past five years how much money
they printed it was you know
unprecedented amounts of money we are
basically ascribing to an unprecedented
uh uh monetary policy modern monetary
theory is is essentially it's a new idea
it's not been tested we don't know
exactly how much stress the system can
take and it so far thankfully things
haven't gone terribly wrong but there's
no reason to believe that something
wouldn't happen can't happen tomorrow
everything fall apart and a lot of the
money that got spent over the past few
years got spent really willy-nilly like
I know that and watch I remember in
Washington state a bunch of the money
that went out that was like extra
unemployment actually went to Africa
there was like a whole scam going on
they were like oh we're unemployed don't
check our IP addresses and nobody did
yeah it's just the first Republic got
really into nfts
they got all those board Apes
in the Donald Trump nfts you know what
they were really doing apparently is
what it's been reported they were giving
interest-only loans to ultra wealthy
individuals they would basically they
were just buying penthouses for rich
people and then like no money down like
BLM seems like like it seems like the
Titanic hit the iceberg a long time ago
and the rich people have been extracting
as much as they can to bail out as it's
sinking to the ground I mean that's like
2 000 people left New York 2 000
millionaires left New York it was like
250 000 people left in Manhattan which
is also higher income yeah and then it
was like but the there were like
actually 2 000 legit Millionaires and
then where do they go Florida I guess a
bunch of them went to Florida yeah New
Zealand bunkers or something yeah just
get the hell out they can get to Montana
where they have the the old nuclear
silence I gotta give a shout out to Jim
Cramer he's undefeated
undefeated he has that tweet where he's
like First Republic good bank he's like
ready move move to New York go over
there pack your stuff up he said
something positive about Bitcoin the
other day and I'm like no
well no maybe that's the one thing where
it's like maybe I'll move my assets If
he if he's recommended I'm getting out
because I don't know what's going on
here but maybe maybe he's created the
inverse Kramer effect where they
actually are good Banks but by him
shouting it out everyone panics and then
pulls their money out he's like I want
to burn it all down he's just been
studying the economy for years and he
sees the corruption in the system I will
be its Reckoning yeah if you're behind
the scenes he's just calling these
institutions out so people lose faith in
them yes he's actually yeah he's burning
it all down if he'd made that tweet in
uh in Mandarin Bitcoin would have
crumbled because what the people in
China would have understood but what I
find really funny about this story is
that there's a whole bunch of stories
where it's like there is no banking
crisis experts say it's all you know
media nonsense and don't worry nothing
bad's happening and like it from March
until three days ago all of the news
stories were there is no banking crisis
it's all being overhyped and then like 2
two days before the US government seizes
the second largest bank uh its second
largest collapse seized by the US
government ABC runs a story saying is
the banking collapse over and I'm like
wait wait wait wait wait wait y'all were
saying there was no banking collapse in
the corporate media and then right
before this collapse you're like is it
is it over well answer was no but here's
my concern JP Morgan gets 50 billion
dollars in Federal Financing so
basically we are maybe not the taxpayer
but we as regular people are all footing
the bill because
like all it's just tied to to the FDIC
is supposed to be for us it's supposed
to be insuring our money right and
instead they're using it to finance the
sale to JP Morgan but here's my thought
process yo uh it's just me and I
understand why people in media will just
say like everything's fine everything's
fine
because they don't want to run on the
banks so recognizing that I'm gonna be
completely honest if I had money in JP
Morgan I would have gone first thing
today and pulled it all out all of it
every penny every penny because JP
Morgan just bought a necrotic necrotic
multi-billion dollar asset with 84
branches and and with government
financing meaning the only reason they
made this the only reason this is
possible is the government because I'll
just say the FDIC gave 50 billion
dollars in fixed rate financing so JP
Morgan was not capable of absorbing this
without the federal government's
intervention so I'm kind of like why
should I believe they can rescue this
failing this this failure and the other
thing too is the FDIC has said that they
were going to put a new program in place
to make Banks pay more money for this
Bank bailout Insurance Fund like that's
coming up too
I just I think JP Morgan is not going to
be able to handle it well are any of the
banks going to be able to handle this
kind of thing and they're all going to
be expected to pay into this new fund
right the argument I guess was JP Morgan
was saying that when people fled First
Republic they went to Chase and they
brought that money with them but imagine
you're like on a sinking ship right and
you're like quick everyone jump to that
ship yeah and then the other ship is
like yeah actually you know we're we're
that's part of our Fleet too and we're
like connected to it they're going to be
like we don't have that many lifeboats
we were running from from that bank and
now our money's right back with them I
mean it at this point it really is a
situation where people are are kind of
on their own figuring out where the safe
places to go is because there there's
got to be contagion from this bank that
or from the other banks that are going
to be brought to JPMorgan I mean I
assume JP Morgan is alleged to be able
to handle it the the government is going
to back it up but again what happens if
something unprecedented happens what if
there's they can only handle because the
government because the FDIC gave him 50
billion dollars yeah a promissory note
so if JP Morgan could not do it on their
own without government support why would
I assume they're going to be able to
manage this properly
because the government will keep writing
checks so it's essentially you're
betting on the US government so why
didn't the government just write a check
to First Republic and keep them afloat I
as I don't know exactly what the thought
process was but something else going on
there then I would then my issue there
is
okay I think if they're going to write a
50 billion dollar check to JP Morgan why
not just write a 50 billion check to
First Republic because they don't want a
national because then it will be looked
at as nationalizing the bank if the
government I know but I think that is it
I think it's going to be a situation of
just they're going to say oh well it's
not nationalized because JP Morgan's
running it blah blah even though they're
financing or funding it if the
government just says we're taking over
and we're going to send Regulators from
the SEC in or whatever the you know
whatever the the regulating body is if
they just send them in then it becomes a
situation where they're going to be like
no it's government right because that
was the problem or that was the concern
back in 2008 they didn't want to have
Goldman Sachs look like it was owned by
the government and people are allergic
to nationalizing they want someone they
want to be taken over but they want a
private company to be the one doing it
and at the very least so that way they
can say that it's not nationalized the
government didn't take over the bank if
there's an ulterior motive it just
sounds like they're being shady and once
again if I use Chase I would be gone
that's just me I mean and I get it the
reason why people like Jim Cramer come
out and they're like everything's fine
everything's fine even though it's not
is because they don't want to create the
self-fulfilling prophecy where you go in
the media say everything's not fine
causing a run of the banks
right svb was like Twitter conversation
and then there was a run on the bank
well it's also like and First Republic
was the same thing when they started
getting hit people started pulling their
money out causing it to collapse right I
wonder if Occupy Wall Street activists
are cheering this on right now it's like
everything they've ever wanted well they
probably have all their money in Chase
yep I mean like if I sat you down and I
was like Tim
everything's gonna be okay do you
understand everything's all right it's
not your it's okay everything's fine
you'd be like what's gonna happen
whenever someone feels the need to
reassure you it's like um Good Will
Hunting it's not your fault it's not
your fault I'm thinking more stop saying
that do you remember do you remember at
the end of The Dark Night
when not to spoil it or anything but
when Harvey Dent's like have you ever
told someone everything's gonna be okay
when you know it isn't that's Jim Cramer
right now so if you have any idea what
it's like someone should make that Meme
where he's yelling at Jim Cramer because
that's literally what the dude has done
I never do that I never say everything's
gonna be okay based yeah I mean I don't
know if it's going to be okay I do I do
know that so like eventually we're all
going to be dead like yeah okay but that
might you know that's okay that's when
everything's actually okay right okay
has no meaning well you have nothing to
complain about it
but I mean like living a long and
healthy life and dying of old age trying
to buy loved ones is okay no that sounds
great right so everything will be
aspired to that kind of death I mean
it's it's just the Human Experience you
know I'm just saying I I understand why
everyone's coming out and saying it's
gonna be okay but you got to understand
the people who are saying that to you
they may claim to have Noble reasons but
they're pulling their assets and they're
putting it somewhere else
where do you put it China yeah that
doesn't sound like putting it in their
mattresses eventually we'll have some
sort of like tariff situation we won't
be able to get our money out of there
well yeah for sure but if you're a rich
people don't worry about I mean Panama
right El Salvador people they're
probably buying tons of Bitcoin so like
I wouldn't be surprised if Bitcoin
skyrockets there have been predictions
that a few months ago someone several
people were predicting that Bitcoin
would hit a million dollars soon yeah
and uh who was that uh that that was
that he's an economist or whatever and
he said it was going to hit a million
dollars and he would make a bet with
somebody that it would everybody said
the amount the amount of increase in in
Bitcoin due to him creating this
narrative is going to cover any
potential losses from giving away a
million dollars they didn't believe him
but the point he made was that the banks
are insolvent they're holding a bunch of
they're holding way more liabilities and
they have assets and and their
unrealized losses and as soon as this
comes in the next few months the dollar
is going to collapse Bitcoin is going to
Skyrocket and then this happens you know
the second biggest collapse in U.S
history
happening with two other major collapses
in the span of a couple months what's
interesting is is uh Chase like JP
Morgan in the first place back in like
19 whatever 1913 or something like that
he didn't when there was like a run on
banks there was a run on local banks and
all the local banks had their money
invested with regional Banks and the
regional Banks had their money invested
with you know banks in New York and
everything so when there was a run on
the banks the local banks the they
couldn't get their money out fast enough
to cover it because it was all invested
basically Upstream
um but JP Morgan thought that there
should be a private banking back
situation where like it was not
nationalized at all but all of the banks
got together and basically created their
own kind of you know FDIC but it was for
the banks themselves and private and
instead it ended up being
um you had like the Federal Reserve Act
so someone someone uh chatted that uh
Valley National Bank is also falling
right now and I just looked it up and
like it's it's in the news they're
they're starting to fall now minus 20 oh
my God that's gracious does anybody have
a clear memory of what it was that made
the average person realize that the
banking crisis was happening in 2008 if
as far as I remember
probably I thought it was like Lehman it
wasn't it Lehman well Lehman Brothers
and bears were banks that were involved
but I'm wondering what it was that made
the average person was it because I
thought it was because the the CR the
companies like GE weren't able to get
credit from other companies to to make
their payroll and I'm wondering if there
has to be a catalyst to make people the
average person aware if they're not you
know it's like if you don't have your
money in any of these particular four
these four Banks you kind of might just
not really pay attention oh a bank
failed and then go about your day and it
doesn't really affect you unless there's
something that makes it go
you know makes it makes it become
everyone's problem and I'm wondering if
there's if anyone has any insight on
that what what it was back in 2008 if or
if there's something very little money
in 2008 so I don't really remember at
all speaking of having very little money
let's jump to our next story hold on
this is not Financial advice but I'm
gonna buy a bunch of nfts print them out
and stuff them in my mattress
that's a really clever idea great idea
thank you the banks will never get it
because that's the good pay use the good
picture paper too the stuff like the
glossy stuff exactly will retain their
value they're just different nfts of
your face exactly I'll make my own nfts
Drive the price down buy them up then
stuff them in my mattress once the price
point is high because they're yours not
Financial advice you just figure out
what they're worth that's basically what
Sam bankman freed did thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time